-Congrats on the album,
"Takin' It Back."
-Thank you.
-We have lots to talk about.
Thank you for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
I'm just -- It's not every day
you're on the show
with T. Swift, bro.
[ Laughter ]
-Stop, come on.
You guys must know each other,
right?
-Just briefly.
[ Laughter ]
-Now you're British
all of a sudden, too?
-Briefly.
-"Briefly."
-Oh, my God, it's the nerves.
-It's the nerves.
-Okay, I'm here.
-Last time I saw you was
when we played "Password"
together, wasn't it?
-Yes.
-You were very --
-Yes!
-"Yes!"
-I was very aggressive then too.
-You were very competitive
and very funny.
-Yes. Oh, thank you.
-And then you ended up almost --
-Winning.
-Yeah, and destroying me
at the end.
You got in there by the end.
But there was one word that you
didn't get that made me laugh.
-Oh, we're going to bring
this up?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I mean, it just --
It was starting to
trend on Twitter.
So, I was like, "Oh, yeah."
You didn't know
what manscaping was.
-Listen!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you know what manscaping is?
-Yeah.
[ Audience says "yes" ]
-Whatever.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Everyone's like, "Yeah."
But, yeah, that was interesting,
you never -- you're like --
-I --
-Yeah, you're like --
-Mama never taught me
what that really meant.
-"Mama never taught me."
-My mom's here tonight
and my dad.
-Hey, we love you, Mom and Dad.
You gotta be proud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah, there they are.
Hey, Dad, come on.
There's your dad. Come on.
You gotta be very proud.
Is he a happy grandpa?
-Shoulders back.
-Happy grandpa too?
-Grandpa?
-Yeah. Well, I mean --
Well, you got a baby.
-Huh?
Oh, oh, he's a grandpa now.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-I was like -- I was like,
"Auntie Flo is here,
but I don't know if my grandpa
is here."
I thought you were
surprising me.
-Your dad is a grandpa. Yes.
-My father is a grandfather.
-Your father is a grandfather.
-I have a baby!
-Yes! How is baby, then?
-Yes. He's perfect.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-He's perfect?
-He's perfect.
I just dragged him all over
Australia and now here
and he finally at the end of
the trip says, "Mama,"
which is great.
-Oh, it's the best in the world.
-Right? He did say "dada" first.
Thank you for your kids book.
He has kids books.
-Yeah, thank you. Yeah.
I was asking -- I was like,
"What music is he into?"
Because sometimes, the kids'
music are like,
"Is it baby shark?
Is it this theme?"
-I saw Saucy Santana.
-Yes.
-Singing "Booty" on here.
-And that's my son's
favorite song.
-Booty, booty, booty, booty,
booty, booty, booty, booty.
-Every time we get him out of
the bathtub to, like, dry him
off, we're like,
"Yeah, I know you like
my booty, booty, booty, booty."
And he cracks up.
He watches the music video
every night to go to sleep.
-He's so cute.
Can we talk about
"Takin' It Back"?
-Okay.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-What inspired
the album title here?
-Oh, all my albums start with T
for Trainor,
my family represent.
-That's right.
-When I started writing this
album, a co-writer said,
"You know, I had some artists
coming in here saying,
'I want to do
the Meghan Trainor sound.'"
And I was like,
"You mean the doo-wop?"
And then on TikTok,
title was blowing up.
And I was like, "The universe is
speaking and I am listening."
So I wanted to take it back
to doo-wop times.
-So you listened to the fans.
You're like, "Yeah, you want it?
I'll give it to you."
-Yeah. Give what you want.
-Yes.
You worked with an incredible
producer on this album.
In fact, we have a clip.
Here's Meghan in the studio
with her producer, who happens
to be a 1-year-old.
Take a look.
-Oh.
♪♪
[ Audience aws ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You just -- You just kiss him
and hold him all day long?
-Yeah, I snuggle him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, that's what
you have to do.
-You have to.
-Did becoming a mom change
how you write some of the songs
on your new album?
-Oh, yeah.
I'm, like, way better.
You know what I mean? I just --
[ Laughter ]
Well, everything is
way more important. You know?
I have, like,
a big fear of death,
and now it's just times
a thousand.
But I'm like, "Everything means
so much more."
And you can hear that
in my lyrics.
-Yeah.
-It's not sad. It's happy.
-No, this is a happy, happy,
happy record.
I'm trying to think about here
which one is my favorite jam.
-You listened?
-Yes, of course I did.
In fact, I saw the video,
by the way,
in Times Square
on a giant billboard.
-You go to Times Square?
-Of course.
[ Laughter ]
I always go to
Bubba Gump Shrimp.
I go, "Hey, what's up,
everybody?"
-Oh, love it.
-Of course. Absolutely.
You're performing a song for us
after the break.
-"Made you look."
-Is it -- Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's the video I love,
"Made You Look."
When you do a new song,
do you -- when you perform --
-It's terrifying.
-It is?
-Yes.
-I was going to say,
do you get nervous?
-[ Scottish accent ]
I'm shakin' in my boots.
[ Laughter ]
Don't ask me what that was.
-"Shaking in my boots"?
Now you're a Scot?
"I'm shakin' in my boots."
-But also,
it's a T. Swift night,
so everyone is gonna watch this!
-Yes!
-So, I'm like --
-Yes, Taylor is watching this
as well.
-No, she's not!
-Yes, she is!
[ Laughter ]
But don't you --
You can't be nervous.
You're Meghan Trainor.
-I'm so nervous!
I fall on this stage.
It's where I'm triggered
because I fell here.
-You fell once here.
-I did fall once,
and you laid with me.
And I thank you for that.
[ Laughter ]
I'll never forget that.
-Remember that?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Remember?
-No, no.
-I remember because --
-Remember her shame?
-No, because you're
the greatest because I go --
You're doing this whole thing
and then you're dancing
as well as singing,
which you don't --
-That's hard to do.
-No, you're very talented.
But then that last move happened
and you were on heels
and you fell and then I went
over and laid down next to you
and go, "We'll be right back
with more 'Tonight Show.'"
-Yeah.
-But then I go, "Do you want --
Let's do it again if you want to
do it again.
No problem.
Don't worry about it."
And you go,
"No, that really happened.
I'm not afraid of that.
I'm not ashamed.
Let's show everyone
what happened."
And that's why we love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's why we love you.
-I'm real.
-You're performing the song
from "Takin' It Back"
after the break.
Meghan Trainor, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Made You Look"
when we come back.
More "Tonight Show."